[Music]
good afternoon everybody my name is
ganesh taylor and i'm your host today
for this uh really exciting debate
called technology savior or threat
so
as the power of tech giants grows ever
greater and science is seen to despoil
the planet and use ever greater
resources
many are increasingly critical of
science
yet no one is handing in their
technology we included
should we stop complaining about big
tech and science and recognize
uh and welcome the many improvements to
our lives that they have brought
or are the changes brought about by
science and technology profoundly
damaging our personal well-being and to
the planet and should we be seeking to
reign in their power before it is too
late
so
joining me uh to help us tackle and
think about these questions we have a
star spangled uh series of speakers
and first up we have
uh tob bjord who is uh the professor of
philosophy at oxford university one of
the professors i should say rather than
the singular professor unfortunately
maybe um anyway toby is the spearhead of
both the effective altruism movement and
the existential risk space
his most recent bestseller the precipice
combines his expertise on risk
catastrophe
and morality and serves as an
existential guidebook to anyone
concerned about the impending end of
humanity
fabulous thank you toby
then we also are joined by fotini
marcopodo
who is an ex-quantum physicist and was
leading with a founding member even of
the perimeter institute for theoretical
physics
she has a phd in quantum gravity
and leaving behind her space-time
theories she's gained an education in
design and engineering and now works on
building the world's first empathic
technology and using complex systems
science to build new tools for
understanding and guiding society so
welcome fertini anna lemke one of the
first physicians
in the us to speak openly about the
opioid epidemic
she has repeatedly worked uh in cases of
federal litigation against big pharma
but is perhaps best known to the general
public for her appearance in the 2020
netflix documentary the social dilemma
her forthcoming book dopamine nation
explores how digital products hijacked
our reward pathways and how they
undermine our individual agency
last but by no means least we are also
joined by dallas campbell
dallas is a celebrated science educator
who presents some of television's most
popular factual shows including bango's
the theory and the gadget show as an
ambassador for stem education he has uh
won many plaudits for his services to
the public understanding of science
including an honorary fellowship from
the british
science association and honorary life
membership for his work at the royal
institution
he is of course also as we can tell a
proud owner of a space suit replica
which has already entertained us all
greatly
so
having done that uh introduction i'm
going to invite all of you to answer the
question
will technology be our savior
or our downfall
and um just to get us started dallas uh
in no particular order i'm going to ask
you to step in please dallas it's such a
hard
well this is the thing it's this it
depends on who i've read or what i've
watched at the time so when i was
watching anna on television was like oh
it's a downfall and then toby is much
more oh it's about you so it it kind of
depends on that there's that famous
niels bohr quotation that
um
prediction is very difficult especially
if it's about the future which i i sort
of generally uh subscribe to see i wish
i was if i was elon musk or if i was
stephen hawking or something i could
give you the sort of very pessimistic
view and tell us we're all going to
um
uh you know be taken over by super
intelligent machine learning et cetera
et cetera i always think that those
sorts of headlines those doom and gloom
headlines are the headlines that grabs
everyone's attention
but i don't think i am like that i sort
of i'm very much of the opinion i think
that the future is going to be what we
make of it
um there was a you know the famous
swiss scientist i think he was swiss
conrad gassner of course writing about
the latest um technological handheld
device
and the always-on culture that culture
of
being bombarded with information and how
that would be the ruination of uh of
civilization and of course conrad
gastner wrote that
that that piece in the sort of 1500s and
of course he was talking about the
printing press and so one thing we can
do if we can't predict the future is
look at sort of patterns in the past and
the one thing we do know about the past
is that the history of science and
technology is filled with fear and and
and premonitions of doom and gloom
um which never sort of turn out to be
quite has how we expect i mean i
remember growing up as a kid
all the fear was about um video nasties
and computer games would would would
ruin our concentration everything else
and it's never quite as simple as that
so questions like is it going to be our
savior or is it going to be our downfall
i don't think it's going to be either i
think it's going to be something we
can't even imagine um yes we are on a
the brink of an extraordinary new uh
technological revolution um but how it
pans out is going to be dependent on
what we decide to do and the one thing
that we do know is humans are very messy
that's my fence-sitting answer to your
question i love it yeah a bit of a bit
of um agency on on the behalf of human
beings that call for agency like it um
anna what do you think so yeah well
so uh a patient of mine a young man in
his early 20s came in seeking help for
debilitating depression and anxiety he
was also playing video video games most
of his waking hours
um 20 years ago i would have prescribed
him an an antidepressant first thing
um today instead what i did was
recommended to him what i recommend to
many of my patients which is to
abstain from screens for an entire month
a dopamine fast
and um
he said why on earth would i do that
playing video games is the only thing
that gives me any relief from my
depression but what i did was i
explained to him how these are really
drugs
and when we engage in them we release a
lot of dopamine in our brains reward
pathway and the way that the brain
adapts to that is to immediately down
regulate our own dopamine transmission
our own dopamine receptors essentially
putting us into
a dopamine deficit state and if we
engage in our drug for many hours every
day for long periods of time we
essentially get into a permanent or
semi-permanent dopamine deficit state
so i suggested to him that by abstaining
he could reset his dopamine balance he
did it he came back a month later he
felt better than he had in many years i
see that in my patients a lot
and he was surprised and the reason that
he was surprised is because when we're
chasing dopamine it's really hard to see
cause and effect we really do need to
get that distance from it in order to
see the true impact on our lives
um and the good news is that most of us
after a period of abstaining can go back
to using these drugs in moderation
as long as we keep in mind what it's
doing to our brains so um my key message
here is that the devices themselves are
drugs they're also a conduit to
traditional drugs that have existed for
millennia and they also are a conduit to
drugs that didn't even exist before
texting tweeting gaming gambling the
social media posts the washington post
you name it
so um i think that we need to be very
thoughtful going forward about how we
engage with the technology and there
definitely is a dark underbelly that we
need to recognize and i really really
hope that schools and families and
parents are educated about this because
um you know it's not you can't just give
your kid an ipad and walk out the door
wow okay anna that's some powerful stuff
um fatini as a person who's developing
technologies how do you how do you come
back to that and how do you feel about
the subject of savior or downfall
so before we do the technology let me
clarify because you
uh also put science in
the target in the beginning and um
so science is just describing how things
are
um it's a technology that we make out of
that
where we should be having a discussion
um not on the science uh
and a lot of
the fear about the science is like when
you look at science fiction it's really
technology fiction right so
it is a technologies that
we should be discussing at a very basic
level
uh like other the other said
i think it depends what we do with it so
you can you can take a pencil and you
can write a poem and you can poke your
eye with it um
if you want
to
think about it in
its whole context and what it means for
us
basic thing is that
humans are the animal that makes tools
that makes technologies
and
as we do that we co-evolve and we change
we have thumbs because we made tools
to kill animals
every time that we make tools
we change with them
also the technologies that we make are
not just stuff not just tools they are
ways that we design how we interact with
each other so their physical
technologies are the tools and social
technologies which is how we arrange the
societies that we live in
um and you might have
i don't know hunter-gatherer tribes or
you have the silicon valley tribe and
they live on top of capitalism and
democracy in different systems
and
if you
are going to be looking at what the
effect of technology is there are all of
these different layers of technologies
that they interact with each other and
you can't just pick one
and say whether that one is good or not
so the the key thing that is happening
now and that
makes those questions super interesting
is that the power of our technologies
has hugely increased it's basically
comparable to our own power and at this
point when you're talking about how we
are going to co-evolve with these
technologies in the future there are
actually there are choices like what
anna was saying it's important to be
aware of what our tools are doing to us
because that allows you to have
some sense of
control or thinking about what's
happening but it's also important to
keep in mind all the different layers
that feed into uh the technologies that
we're making and a lot of
uh
the
the key decisions are actually being
made in the technology that moves the
money around
in the technologies rather than the
technology
the device itself
um
so
you should consider the feedbacks of the
different structures that we are
inventing
that's a really cool point and toby i
actually saw you nodding along so i i
assume you want to come back to that
immediately but yeah what do you think
yeah so uh will will technology be our
savior our downfall um
it's yeah it's hard to know how to
answer that but i want to address it uh
head on and and take it quite literally
uh my work uh directly concerns the
risks of human extinction uh including
the role that technology plays in that
so uh the history of humanity uh we've
been around for about two hundred
thousand years
uh and over uh ten thousand generations
we've seen a uh a steady and uh
accelerating uh
increase in an escalation of power uh
power over the world around us and that
this has been fueled largely by
technology
uh and in the 20th century this power
reached uh a kind of a new level uh
where it was the first time with the
development of nuclear weapons that we
had the uh capacity to destroy ourselves
uh and we we reached this point of power
uh before we developed the wisdom uh to
ensure that we don't
and this uh this moment uh
we'd always been subject to risks uh
natural risks of extinction such as
asteroid impact or something like that
uh but
that risk is is actually quite low and
can be can be measured and bounded
scientifically from the fossil record
but for the first time we've reached a
point where the risks to humanity from
within exceeded the risks from the
natural world
and and ultimately we need to get out of
that situation
probably by managing those risks and
working out the right ways to do so
or it'll be our downfall
and i would put uh that the chance in
the next hundred years that humanity is
destroyed by natural risks at about one
in ten thousand
uh
whereas my best guess on technological
risks is about one in six uh much higher
so in that sense technology is is likely
to be our downfall but if we don't
progress in technology um then our
downfall in the long run is all but
assured um
we could only go another 10 000 or so
centuries before we fall victim to the
natural risks typical species lasts
about a million years
but the earth will remain habitable for
about a billion years and only
technology uh promises a way out to kind
of really live up to our potential
uh so it's kind of at the heart of
whether humanity survives or fails but
it's very much a double-edged sword and
i would i would echo the other panelists
uh to put agency at the foreground and
to say that that we should focus in some
ways less on whether technology is good
or bad uh and perhaps more on the ways
in which is good and bad and on how we
can make it good how we can make it work
for us
and i would suggest that um certainly we
can't stop uh with technology uh but we
could reinvest uh more of the games of
technology into responsible steering and
stewardship of technology uh and to have
you know uh some fraction of the number
of kind of best and brightest people
that we see in the space of technology
onto the the area of governance of
technology and
and yeah making it work for humanity
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas